[Music]
good afternoon and welcome to the law
and crime Network I'm Angelica Spanos we
have to live cases we've been following
and new developments with both of those
first a verdict is in in the trial of
Kamiya hassel in michigan we'll bring
you that as soon as we can hear coming
up but we're also going to be following
day seven of the Rosenbaum trial in
Georgia before we get to all of that we
have new details out in Jeffrey
Epstein's bail hearing from this morning
a federal judge decided if the
financière will be granted bail in this
high-profile sex trafficking case Judge
Richard Berman announced his decision
this morning at 11:30
our very own chief investigative
correspondent Brian Ross is here with us
Brian as I said we know that the judge
denied bail that's right he agreed with
prosecutors that Jeffrey Epstein could
be a flight risk the prosecutors had
said he had limitless resources now
Epstein's lawyers had agreed to hire
private security guards have him wear a
GPS ankle bracelet so he could stay
inside his 77 million dollar mansion
here in New York he also agreed to post
the mansion as collateral for a bond but
the judge said that would not be enough
and what were some of the other reasons
that Epstein's attorneys were putting
out there of why he should be released
well they said he had since his guilty
plea to a misdemeanor charges in Florida
had been following the straight and
narrow path he had not violated the law
he had met all the conditions imposed on
him back then and they also gave a
glimpse of their possible strategy when
this goes to trial that these charges
amount to essentially double jeopardy
for him since he had pleaded guilty to
the same facts in Florida and they say
had been prosecuted and punished for
those facts and a big talker out of this
has been this passport they had found an
expired passport in a safe in his house
and it has his picture on it a different
name I believe and it was used in the
80s it was in the 80s to enter countries
in Europe and Saudi Arabia and his
lawyer said he had that for the reasons
of personal protection he
we wanted to hide the fact that he was
Jewish in case terrorists somehow
kidnapped him in the Middle East where
he was doing lots of business he says he
would turn over that passport as proof
that he wasn't Jeffrey Epstein he was
somebody who was not Jewish that's what
the lawyers argued in papers to the
judge and one of the things that you
mentioned before was how they're gonna
have a private guard with him a GPS
monitor why are they asking for that
well they were saying that would
guarantee that he would show up for the
hearing for the trial and of course bail
is only meant to make sure that you
guarantee the person will appear for the
hearing or if there's a possible risk or
a threat to the safety of the community
the judge also was given evidence that
he in the past had offered payments to
people who might be witnesses against
him and also the prosecutor said he
should not get special treatment just
because he's wealthy he shouldn't be
able to buy his own private jail and
what do we know about this trial going
forward do we know many details yet I
know this is obviously new today well
this is due today that means he'll be
sitting in the Metropolitan Correctional
Center in downtown Manhattan here in New
York City while he awaits his trial the
sex trafficking charges are very
extensive and prosecutors also presented
evidence they discovered when they went
through his safe at his mansion here in
New York finding hundreds if not
thousands of pictures of naked women
many of them they say were underage
women of course he was accused and
pleaded guilty to abusing dozens of
teenage girls in Florida and in New York
they also found 75 seventy thousand
dollars in cash a big quantity of
diamonds fraud diamonds one of them 2.3
eight carats so they were arguing that
given all that he had the means if he
wanted to to take off and try to find a
place where he can avoid the possible
outcome of this trial and they say
because if found guilty he is likely
facing the sentence of up to 45 years
and for somebody who's 66 years old
that's a life sentence right all right a
lot of interesting stuff with this case
we will be following here for plenty
more on the Epstein
case watch Brian Ross investigates
that's happening tonight here on lawn
crime at 5:30 Brian thanks for being
here today good to be here
[Music]
[Music]